i'm joined now by the director of the
oxford vaccine group and chairperson of
the joint committee on vaccination and
immunization professor andrew pollard uh
great to talk to you today uh sir andrew
it's been an extraordinary 12 months
hasn't it in the life of both covert and
the astrazeneca vaccine what have we
learned
well i think it as you say it's been a
quite extraordinary year that we've just
been through from at this time last year
when we were just starting roll out of
vaccines
with a lot of uncertainty still about
how long it would take to start to bring
the pandemic under control but i think
on on that day
last year i certainly felt that this
that was the beginning of the end of the
pandemic uh clearly as the years gone on
um we've seen the most remarkable
rollout of vaccines not just the oxford
vaccine of all of them around the world
with
now
around nine billion doses
that have been distributed and the most
incredible impact on
the the pandemic
so that we're in a very much better
place today than we were we were
today with very large numbers of cases
in the community um but still
very good control of severe disease
as a result of vaccination they've been
extraordinary
are you worried that we're becoming a
little complacent
um no i don't think we are being
complacent
at all actually i mean we're
today in a situation where there's very
good monitoring much better than it was
before globally
trying to understand
uh how best to make sure
everyone in the world is protected um as
well as is possible and now we're in
this new period of transition to
work out now that there's very high
levels of immunity in countries like
ours how do we transition to a situation
where society is open
and we maintain protection of the
vulnerable in the population
and that is the the programs that have
been happening over the last few months
with the doses being given and trying to
manage the number of cases so the nhs is
protected um but as we go forwards into
the year ahead uh working out better how
to live with the virus um is going to be
the critical next step
you mentioned third dose well of course
countries like israel they're already
doing false doses do you foresee a
position where we are going to be pretty
much getting jabbed every six months or
so
well it's just not from a global
perspective affordable sustainable or
deliverable to give forth doses to
everyone on the planet every every six
months and remember that today
less than 10 percent of people in
low-income countries have been even had
their first dose and so the whole idea
of regular fourth doses globally is just
not um
sensible
now it may be that
as the science evolves that we can work
out who the most vulnerable are in
populations and target future boosters
to those individuals to maintain their
protection but for the vast majority of
people
who are vaccinated the risk now is
extremely low of severe coverage of
those who've had three differences and
it's likely that we'll reach a point
where we're focusing those booster doses
on those who most need them and of
course at this moment we don't know what
that looks like does that mean that we
need updated vaccines each year like we
do with flu we just use the same
vaccines for boosters we need more data
to make those decision decisions
and in terms of those who haven't had
vaccinations um there has been a lot of
misinformation out there how frustrating
is it for you
as a scientist who's been hugely
involved in in the science of
vaccination all your life um
to see some of the the stuff that is
repeated usually online and what impact
do you think this has had has it
actually
caused people to die who might not have
died
well there's no doubt that anything
which um
makes people uncertain or hesitant about
being vaccinated um particularly
those who are in vulnerable groups
that puts their life at risk and we've
definitely
seen the effects of
some parts of the commentary some of the
misinformation which have had a major
impact on
people's confidence in vaccination and
so there's no doubt in my mind that
during the course of the last year some
people will have died because of
misinformation and that just shows how
critical it is it's another type of
virus that spreads very readily around
the world
is there anything you would have done
differently now looking back over the
last 12 years because yes you've been
involved in vaccines all this time but
it's been unlike anything else in terms
of the scale
um well i i mean our
major role in uh 2020 was in vaccine
development and i think the one thing um
that i would have liked to have been
able to do differently uh would be to
run much larger clinical trials and we
couldn't do that
partly because
the human resource is required to do
that that we needed at the time
but largely just we didn't have the
manufacturing capacity to make enough
doses to run larger trials
the reason why that's so important is if
we could have done that we may have had
a vaccine a month or two earlier and
with 10 000 people dying every day at
the end of 2020
it really shows you if you can just make
a few weeks difference
to shave off the time it takes to
develop actions you can save many lives
around the world and so i think that for
me is the the biggest thing that if we
were starting this again that would be
to find ways of actually having more
doses to run larger trials and get an
answer quicker
and during the course of uh the the last
year
um i don't think um
that we have to we should shy away from
the problem that we've had from a global
community perspective
which has been timely vaccination of
vulnerable people everywhere millions of
people have died during 2021 because
they weren't vaccinated um in before
they got disease and many of those
people died because they didn't have
access to vaccines so the equitable
distribution of vaccines the other thing
which i think
we really need to think about how to
address not just for future pandemics
but even today in this pandemic to make
sure and the people are protected
everywhere
in terms of new variants because we have
a vaccine as it were for covert
generally
do we need to be less concerned about
new variants or should we be as equally
concerned i mean it does appear that
omicron is possibly not as serious for
lots of people as delta was but there
could be another one just around the
corner tomorrow couldn't there
well it would be great if uh if we're in
a situation now where the cost to the
virus of being able to spread now that
was we're vaccinated is that it causes
less severe disease that would be good
i don't think we can be sure at this
moment that future versions of the
coronavirus that the sons and daughters
of omicron
will
be uh
mild
causing mild disease so i think we do
need more time to evaluate that to
understand exactly why omicron seems to
be causing milder disease is this a
direction of travel that the virus has
to go in in order to survive in
continuing
infections
if in indeed we do have ongoing problems
with more severe disease updated
vaccines for the new variants may be one
of the ways that we manage
the living with the virus in the future
do you feel instinctively that we are
over the worst of omicron perhaps uh i
don't want to be overly optimistic or
put words in your mouth
well i don't know with omicron at the
moment i think as the modelers have been
saying in the media over the last few
days one of the real difficulties during
this period is the type of mixing
patterns of people over the holidays
makes it very difficult to
fully assess where we are and i think
that's going to become unclear in the
the weeks ahead
i i don't think we're completely
overwhelmed mikron certainly i mean the
uk but even less so in many other
countries um and there's still some
weeks for the fall of that to play out
but
generally the news is relatively good um
from an overall perspective in that it
does seem to be causing milder disease
but that doesn't mean that our health
system
which is
very much on the edge in normal times is
going to be able to cope with the the
increase in cases and so i think we do
still have to have measures in place
that protect and the health service
during this winter
and what about can i ask you about the
the vaccine manufacturing and innovation
center uh this is a facility that that
creates and tests new vaccines
government's looking at privatizing that
is that something you would welcome is
that useful or does that fill you with
dismay
well i think it's really important to
have access to
the manufacturing facilities that
provide more opportunity for producing
vaccines between pandemics and in
pandemics so that we're much better
prepared
for the future now how that will work
from an operational perspective uh
whether it's privatized or not i don't
know um and that's i think this it sort
of brings some uncertainty for us at
this moment about what the operating
model is
so i think you know we need to wait and
see what that says
uncertainty is never especially useful
is it uh professor andrew pollard
director of the oxford vaccine group
great to talk to you today uh what an
achievement and we're just 12 months
down the line from it thanks so much for
talking to us thank you